hope that magnus keeps his fighting
spirit and tries to
keep what sort of move are we looking
for then from magnus there's options
black black is actually currently a
piece up black has one white bishop but
black's knight is trapped
on that left side of the board it's been
attacked by that quarter pawn it's got
nowhere to go apart from into the center
so it gives itself back
um it's very hard to win this one as
black
okay magnus um now after this trade we
will see the
white queen give check black's queen
will probably just block white's queen
will go back to the center
wesley trying to make the draw magnus no
he's allowed it and okay an early draw
the position repeats itself
and magnus doesn't look too happy
shaking his head yeah
he knows that he probably just wasn't
ready for the game he wasn't in the
right spirit wesley
we do know that he likes to play safety
first in the prelims he doesn't want to
take any risks against someone he thinks
he can't beat
but magnus is definitely shaking his
head is he
disappointed with wesley sort of forcing
him into this or is he disappointed
with him